mr. Kings car man owns the building
least we can get his call right oh I
have almost no cash just $9,000 that's
keys just so you know I would have done
the same thing if you were white that's
good to know yes you're under arrest for
fraud and embezzlement I have faith that
justice system will exonerate me i
sentence you to ten years in a
maximum-security prison does he say ten
years my life is ruined because after 30
days I'm going to prison it's not as bad
as I've heard is it bad teach me how to
survive in prison the way you did tell
me how you know I went to prison
give me your low economic status what
the perceived lack of college education
lack okay statistically you definitely
went to prison
see you tomorrow Convy lose the session
I'm learning so much this is exactly
what I did what reason did you give him
to assume that you went to jail I was
being black you're not exactly a thug
Darnell all I got to do was talk a
little deeper I'm gonna faking that
don't walk away from me it's not prison
writing this program
you master these skills you will survive
in prison who seems you mad don't face
it like what is a mad dog ah
what are you doing James sad dog in you
I think that's a strategy that could
work
please don't sexually assault me I'm
already too sad I go hard 20 some never
defeat this is no longer your house man
people
we stayed acquaintance then we're gonna
wrong part of the yard white boy she
wants to say I'm very confused they go
back where you belong I don't know where
I belong I don't you belong you belong
with me I don't want that incarceration
expert this is my job to prepare you we
are about to simulate a prison life
Romeo old man it's my gang name it's
short for mayonnaise
you